[Music]
hello my name is theresa simon and i'm
an epidemiologist and cannabis
researcher
and today on behalf of my co-authors who
are also either epidemiologists and or
cannabis researchers i'll be presenting
can cannabis derive data be monitored in
the fda affairs database
i'd like to thank the organizers for
inviting me to discuss this important
topic
these are our conflicts of interest we
don't have any however we do support the
choice of individuals to use products
from regulated markets
more on that later
so the takeaways from today
you'll learn that delta 8
tetrahydrocannabinol occurs naturally on
the plant if you didn't know it you'll
learn about the fda affairs database
that there's an increased number of
delta eight thc poisonings in adverse
events
that all cannabis products are not
created equal
and how you can contribute by using our
qr code you can scan it now or hopefully
you'll scan it later
so this is my outline
we'll talk about some background the
objective methods results
our proposal summary and recommendations
and in the background you'll actually
see the chemical
molecule of delta 9 and delta 8 thc and
the only difference is you see that
little 8 up there in the left hand side
next to the nine is that's where the
double bond is between eight and nine
for delta eight where delta nine is
between nine and ten
so a little bit more on hemp versus
cannabis derived delta eight
it's a true false kind of dichotomy
and hemp derived delta eight versus
cannabis derived delta eight
so delta eight is present naturally on
both the hemp and cannabis plants
however in very small amounts it's an
isomer meaning it's synthesized or
artificially derived especially from the
hemp products
in the regulated cannabis it has delta 8
listed on the label and certificates of
analysis it's only sold to qualified
individuals
and currently the extractions from the
hemp plant are being synthesized to
become a schedule 1 drug sometime in
people's bathtubs believe it or not
now some say that if we gave delta 8
versus delta 9 thc product to someone
you may not be able to tell the
difference however i would argue that
point based on some of the adverse
events that we've seen
so here again some background on the
plant composition the only thing i mean
cat cannabis and hemp have lots of
ingredients over 100 cannabinoids and
they all occur
differently at different times of the
plant so you're not going to get
everything all at the same time but the
point of this is to show that delta nine
you might not be able to see this and
delta eight are both present on both
hemp and cannabis
so two years ago there was very little
publicity on delta 8 thc and the past
year actually march 2021 they started
with the first case reports of delta
toxicity were in the news from the
poison control centers around the united
states we're all aware cannabis is not
approved at the federal level and
there's minimal safety data collected at
the state level
but some products that are purchased
refer the consumer to the jurisdiction's
poison control centers if the customer
or consumer experiences an unwanted or
side effect the question for me was
who's minding the store
so what i mean by this is it's hard to
understand how a regulatory body that
allows thc isomers to be sold without
qualification or oversight
especially in unregulated storefronts
where purchasing delta 8 thc seems
easier than buying tobacco or alcohol
state license dispensaries who want to
sell the same type of product have to
follow laws and regulations and
distribute the products including
prohibiting sales to minors i'm going to
emphasize that minors and following
product labeling and accuracy standards
so
has the thc and delta 8 gone wild
i think so because here
let me just show you these two pictures
that are here are places that i actually
i've taken all the pictures in this
presentation and this is a health and
wellness center and they have delta
eight is sold here it's here in new
jersey and another town
outside of just uh
what is perceived to be a plain
chocolate store that i bought lots of
chocolates there regular really high
quality chocolate has a sign out there
want to get high try delta 8.
so
one leaf company based on rolling stone
about a year ago says skirting marijuana
rules to sell thc products in all 50
state states
so
since march of last year
18 states and this changes every day
have either banned or restricted the
selling of delta a products and i want
to show you that some of these states
delaware for example in new york for
example i have taken pictures of delta 8
products in cbd stores in the states
so in september for on september 14
2021 which just so happened to be my
birthday both the fda and the cdc issued
health advisories around delta 8 thc and
case reports of adverse events that have
been reported to
and we'll talk about this
the different
filings which was the poison control
centers and in the fda fares database
so one last thing before we really get
into the data is
based on that
health alerts i since had looked at the
data in social media because from my
perspective i looked at all news avenues
and there was no national coverage of
something like that that covered the
delta eight poisonings
so when i i did a social media
mainstream search and i actually
submitted an abstract and i'm pending uh
hopefully acceptance some of the
the quotes are free weed that gets you
high
and these other pictures the big
billboard was driving down interstate 95
big billboard about got delta 8 thc
and you know it talks about that you
don't need a medical marijuana card
the other pictures that are flashy and
and all different kinds of colors
products that i took pictures of in
delaware and then the d8 gas
best delta 8 thc products
don't remember exactly where i could
pick that one up from but um now the
latest and the greatest is um i was
telling my mother who's actually 83
years old about my delta eight
analysis and she said to me don't say i
think i know that i one of my friends
here that lives in my building
gave me this product and so he said oh
please take a picture of it for me
and so here it is one thousand
milligrams of delta eight high potency
it's a roll-on product
and it's being passed around in the
senior community this among other delta
eight products i will tell you this is
in texas and texas is not one of the
states that has banned it or restricted
it yet
okay so moving on one last thing that
just happened a week ago
is that online shopping for delta 8
products is is very big however shopify
has put a little bit of
clamps down on it
recently and they said that you're not
allowed you know you cannot
um
state that your product has any
medicinal or therapeutic benefit unless
the claim has been approved by the fda
also
i'd like to highlight this the product
contains no more
than 0.3 percent thc that's total thc
regardless of whether it's delta 8 delta
9 and delta 10.
most products that you'll see they'll
say oh it's within the 0.3 thc but it's
only delta 9. that's how they're
skirting it
all right so now down to the study in
the analysis so the objective of the
study was to
evaluate case report data on the nature
and extent of cannabis derived products
specifically delta a thc products in the
fda
adverse event reporting system or the
ferris database so just a little side
note as an epidemiologist and over 25
years of experience monitoring the
safety of
fda approved products i'm very familiar
with the ferris database and this is
what i did immediately one year ago was
to look into this database
so it's a us database it was originally
designed to support the fda's
post-marketing safety surveillance
program for approved drugs and biologics
however it's evolved to a much broader
public health initiative where
healthcare professionals and consumers
can report adverse events or side
effects on any medicine or product
that's on the market
so we looked at
reports for delta 8 thc i looked at
delta 9 thc cannabidiol and cannabis
sativa and the first search was
performed like i said march 2021.
the data presented here is up to
december 31st 2020 the the data that the
fda publishes is by quarters i do have a
little bit of updated data presented in
this but like i said it's it's quarters
so the date is not really two years old
just to make sure that everyone knows
that it's it's actually very current
um one other comment
is that the cannabidiol in the fda
affairs database was all at the dialects
and so then when you do an analysis like
this you need to understand who your
best comparator is
and when you have something as novel as
this like a delta eight thc compound
that's synthetically derived there's no
real comparator and so i used two goal
posts i used cannabidiol cbd which is
actually what they're deriving it from
and cannabis sativa and that's actually
the flower the true plant the delta nine
is in there but the delta nine is
usually based on a positive test
so how does the data get into the fda
fares database so this is a form it's
called the medwatch 3500 form
anyone can download it off the internet
fill it out and submit it to the fda but
it requires work right so it's not just
a simple
way of getting the data in you have to
know about it you have to download it
fill it out and send it back in
now it looks like there's a lot of
pieces of information that occur that
are collected on this form however in
order to submit a form you only need
four
pieces of information to make it a case
and that's the identification of the
person having the event the suspected
product or products and the names of
those the actual reactions or adverse
events
and the sender the person who's
reporting it so healthcare provider
consumer so they have different
checkboxes
so now the methods when you do something
like this these are count data cases we
use something called a proportional
reporting ratio or a prr
it's a disproportionality method and
it's used to identify statistical
associations between products and events
it's a simple way to measure how common
the average of
excuse me
how the adverse event how common the
adverse event is occurring
so the goal is to sort out whether the
average event is occurring
disproportionately higher compared to
your comparator
it's very different from traditional
epidemiologic studies or case analyses
is the two by two table that you end up
um
creating when you do this and so a
cutoff value of two is used as a
benchmark to identify signals i've seen
some people use three however
traditionally it's 2.
so now to the results the overall
results this is the distribution of
cases by reporting year so what we have
here is we go back pretty far in 1999 to
2010
in the background i have the cannabidiol
cases because once it was approved
there's an increase in cases that's
expected that's usually what happens
when a drug gets approved so in the
foreground we have the blue line is the
cannabis sativa there's 580 cases the
delta 8 135 cases i'd like to just point
out you start to see an increase in the
cases just around the approval of the
hemp farm bill
and then the delta nine cases
okay so this is the distribution by age
so most of them occur between 18 and 64
years of age but i'd like to point out
to you under the delta 8 column
there are 14 cases
of underage exposure
so these are the proportional reporting
rates for delta 8 versus cannabis sativa
and what you'll see is
there's a 2 it's actually greater than a
2 for the respiratory thoracic body
system where these are all the body
systems or we call them system organ
class that the average event would fall
into
so two anything greater than two
indicates a potential signal
we also looked at delta eight versus
cannabidiol or cbd now remember most of
this is epidiolex in there
and we see a reporting
ratio of greater than 12 in the
respiratory thoracic body system we also
see an increase in the vascular diseases
and musculoskeletal
so when we look at the delta eight cases
descriptively most of them are between
21 and 35 years of age
22 of the cases occurred in less than 21
year olds
the um
the sex was 48 male
most were reported by a health care
provider
and occurred in the united states 73
percent were deemed serious the most
common occurrence of the average event
was the respiratory system and there
were 14 deaths
so let's look at the event
so the most frequently reported events
on delta 8 for dyspnea followed by
toxicity the various agents
and then drug interactions and then
respiratory disorder cough you'll see
chest pain drug abuse nausea hyrexia
vomiting
and so on
now the respiratory events there's a
whole host of those as well and they're
listed here not meant for you to really
look at them but there's 79 of them so
greater than 50 of the adverse events
reported or respiratory in nature
so now i'm going to show you like i said
earlier i showed you data up to december
31st 2020 and i've done subsequent
queries where i've looked at the data
that's been presented or published for
march 31st 2021 and then again in june
of uh june 30th 2021 and there's a a
small increase in cases over time some
may say well as soon as the march cases
started to
up from the poison control start to to
get some national news you know we start
to see an increase in cases i'm not so
sure because the health
the health advisory never came out until
september of 2021
but again you'll see and so you see here
there's these 14 cases in less than 17
and it shifts there's subsequent data
that may get submitted to the fda and
then they just change the case there are
no duplicates in this to the best of my
knowledge we applied and looked for the
duplications
and then there's 13 now
so when we look at the outcomes
you know the deaths still there's you
know an increase in the number of deaths
related to this where it's a suspect
drug it doesn't say if this is it only
although there are a number of cases
where they just list delta eight where
others they have other
products as well
uh hospitalizations are in the you know
greater than 25 percent continually
serious which means a serious event
means caused the hospitalization it was
life-threatening
that type of an event
is deemed serious non-serious is
something that did not require any sort
of major intervention and it wasn't
serious or life-threatening
and that's about the in the 25 as well
and then respiratory events you know
like i had said is about 50
of the cases all have respiratory events
and the most common is dyspnea followed
by by seizure
so this is the timeline of
our delta eight investigation i'd just
like to take a moment and go through
this so you can see how i've been
monitoring this so
one year ago the first delta eight cases
were in the news from poison control
centers and i looked at this and this is
the 135 cases that i presented today
after i i did this i submitted a freedom
of information
to
the fda asking for the details on all
135 cases
so what's interesting here is is that
when i submitted it i got a phone call
from the fda
and they said that unfortunately they
could only give me 10 cases at a time
and it would take them several weeks to
process that
and over time it might take somewhere
around nine months for me to get the
case details on 135 cases
so i had a conversation with this person
and said i don't understand when i
worked in pharma if we thought that
there was a signal with a product that
we have on the market and we went and
asked for the details of those cases we
would have those cases within you know
two days usually i mean very short time
frame so it was interesting how i was
not able to get a lot of the details you
know
right away
so then um at the same time i presented
very early data
in august of last year
we requested an fda listening session
because someone at the fda actually
heard this presentation from me and made
the suggestion that i contact the fda
so we did i contacted the fda they
granted me an october first listening
session but two weeks before that
listening session the fda and the cdc
issued health warnings and remember i
told you this is my birthday so it was a
great birthday present i was very happy
but it did not receive the national news
that i had hoped that it would get
so here we are um we also continue to
present at different departments of
health
dr marku
works with the health departments in
pennsylvania and delaware and so we
presented the data there
there's been subsequent data extractions
i submitted a manuscript it's on
different a little bit different
analysis than what's published here so
slightly different
um but we launched something called the
buds info adverse event tool and that
was the
qr code early on
and here i am one year later speaking to
you about
the
delta eight poisonings so the theory is
is that in 2018 the hemp farm bill
was
put into place there was an
overproduction of cbd
prices fell and so now derivatives were
made and there that we don't believe
that
for me the delta eight itself
may actually have therapeutic properties
but we don't know if it's the
adulterants or the byproducts that are
actually causing these adverse events so
in many ways it's giving it a bad name
but we'll never know because we'll never
have the opportunity to study it and i
think for me that's probably a major
takeaway that it's unfortunate
that
that
a group
decided to push out something
that may not be so great for for
consumption
okay so the strengths and limitations
the fares data source is limited and
under reported we know that across the
board it doesn't even for for products
that are marketed
uh it's the only known national database
that i know that collects data on
safety
uh for any product specifically cannabis
or derived products
um
events are reported
there's overall exposures unknowns you
have no idea
it's really a case analysis
and signal detection tools
do not imply causation so i'm not saying
that that
delta a caused these adverse events i'm
just saying that there's a potential
signal that one should be aware of
when using certain delta eight products
especially if it's in the unregulated
market
the strength is it's an early
signal detection tool
and an analysis of proportional
reporting ratios have been used as a
measure of association in the past
so in summary there's an increase in
delta 8 thc cases mostly young males in
in the united states have had severe
reactions
these events disproportionately occur in
respiratory events compared to
cannabidiol and cannabis sativa
the fares may be the only source for
national level data right now on
cannabis derived products
so we have some recommendations so
clarification of existing regulations
would be really important because it
seems that many people are using the 0.3
thc just as delta 9 and not
total
informing consumers on the ability to
report adverse effects using the
medwatch form 3500 anyone watching this
and that could be not just cannabis it
could be
anything that you give a patient or if
you
use yourself you can self-report
something
education on products especially label
comprehension is very important have a
look at that certificate of analysis
people think that they're buying cbd
when actually there's delta 8 in the cbd
and they're having an unwanted effect
patient and consumer perspectives are
important i've done some work around
this area where it's not just listing
the adverse event but you know how
debilitating was that adverse event it's
important to really understand their
perspective
a potential to create a sentinel-like
system we've spoken to the fda about
this
a national safety reporting mechanism
for consumers is needed so we have
actually launched something it's called
you can find it at budsinfo.com
it's our beginnings of of trying to
collect cannabis derived
address event data so it doesn't matter
whether it's hemp or cbd or
or cannabis it doesn't matter and we are
seeking partnerships and collaborations
so this is the the website you know by
buds for buds i i and this is the qr
code is coming up next
so scan it now
keep it in your back pocket if you ever
have a patient who may have had unwanted
experience or the patient or consumer
can
complete it themselves
i'd like to thank john simon who's a
co-author and matthew webwire both mph
students at drexel
for
helping me create the form
and getting the qr code launched so
it was great to have them on board with
this project
so thank you
you can contact
me or dr marku
or actually john me or andres the prc
child
and jehovah marcou at marco enterprises
so thank you
you